- THIS IS MY BEAUTIFUL BABY.
HIS NAME IS DONNIE.
- AWW!
- WHAT A PRETTY NAME!
- THANKS.
I GOT IT OUT OF A BOOK.
I DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO
GO THROUGH THE OTHER BOOK.
- "BACARDI, LISTERINE,
ARUGULA."
- OH, THERE'S MY SHOPPING LIST.
[laughs]
NOW CONNIE,
I'M SORRY ABOUT THIS,
BUT FEDERAL GUIDELINES DICTATE
THAT I DON'T HAVE
TO LET YOU BREASTFEED AT WORK
UNLESS YOU GOT A REAL SWEET SET
OF MILKIES.
- WHAT'S WRONG WITH MY BOOBS?
- BESIDES THE FACT THAT YOU ALSO
HAVE A BACK SET?
- AHH! ANTICHRIST!
ANTICHRIST!
- THIS IS GOING TOO FAR,
DENZEL!
- THAT BABY'S EVIL.
I'LL PROVE IT!
- HOW?
- THROUGH SCIENCE.
[cocks gun]
IF I SHOOT IT IN THE FACE
AND IT LIVES, IT'S THE DEVIL.
- OKAY! OKAY!
SHOOT IT
IF IT WILL SHUT YOU UP.
- NO!
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
MY FRIEND, DENZEL!
HOW COULD YOU SAY THOSE
HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT MY BABY?
[crying]
- IT'S JUST A BABY, DENZEL.
- THIS HAS GOT TO STOP.
YOU REALLY UPSET CONNIE.
- NEXT TIME DON'T HESITATE.
AIM FOR THE FONTANELLE.
- ALL RIGHT! ENOUGH WITH
THE BLACK BABY NAMES.
I GUESS I SHOULD APOLOGIZE
TO CONNIE AND DONNIE.
- LEAVE THE GUN!
- FINE!
CONNIE, I'M SORRY...
- [snoring]
- UH, DONNIE, I'M NOT GOOD
AT THIS APOLOGY STUFF, BUT...
I'M SORRY I SAID
YOU WERE THE ANTICHRIST.
MAYBE WHEN YOU GROW UP
A LITTLE, YOU AND I CAN--
- [demonic voice]
APOLOGY ACCEPTED.
- OH, THANKS, DONNIE.
YOU'RE PRETTY COOL.
WAIT, YOU CAN TALK?
- DENZEL, I'M GOING
TO RIP OUT YOUR DICK
AND FEED IT
TO THE DEMONS OF HELL!
[growling]
- [screaming]